oh take it up with helen she's in charge  of the babies and wawa's in the hotel  which is what i'm hearing  helen's not here so i'm telling you and  if i leave  all of my customers leave with me i'm  lionel  now i have to make drinks for the  service park to poor me  it's also draining not that i'm  royalty but so much complaining  where is his loyalty i'm hardly a matron  yet i stand accused decades his patron  just bring me my booze  poor poor me more  more  i'm so i'm so thirsty  i could have been a doctor but i took my  skills to libations  a master serving master glasses  she's finally in perspective the  disrespect  she has shown she lacked and cracked and  lacquered plaster  you can't put a price on magic  but he brings us booze  [Music]  now anyone can be your friend  but lionel brings us  [Music]  he gave me his pants when i needed pants  he built my some science project  he let me call him dad  i'll give you a shoulder  and some free advice  you